einer von ihnen ist oliver knoll ein
deutscher er arbeitet dort als
it-berater norden der hauptstadt mit ihm
sind wir jetzt verbunden herr neuer
schönen guten tag
warum wenn ich das fragen darf sind sie
noch da warum sind sie noch in der
hauptstadt
ich kann dieses wunderbare land die
wunderbare leute die ich einfach im
stich lassen
sie wollen die menschen nicht im stich
lassen heißt es auch sie melden sich
freiwillig zum kampf haben auch sie sich
um eine waffe gekümmert oder wir
verbringen sie jetzt die nächsten tage
und stunden
also tag sind wir versuchen so gut wie
möglich zu arbeiten und den narben
abends und nachts gehe ich halt mit der
miliz auf streife
also von daher stellte zugang zum
kreis mich es darum nicht darum sie zu
benutzen wir haben beängstigende bilder
gesehen seit heute früh von einem 64
kilometer lang militärkonvoi der
russischen armee der kommt auch von
norden renate an die stadt dran sie
kennen die bilder es war eine riesen
gesprächsthema natürlich in der
hauptstadt deshalb haben wir uns auch
geschildert sagen sie einmal was sie
empfinden bei diesen bildern und
vielleicht können sie uns und unseren
zuschauern bis den schildern sie werden
wissen wo der sich ungefähr aufhält wie
gesagt so im nordwesten der hauptstadt
wie weit ist das von ihnen genau
entfernt
also seit heute morgen gibt es wohl
kämpfe in viscontis sind noch ungefähr
zehn kilometer bis zum meer und die
haustüre
erzählen sie uns auch zu ihm kommen
hinzu kommen gerne es ist schon eine
zeitlang her dass ich bei der bundeswehr
war aber wenn wir so einen konvoi
gemacht hätten wären wir von den eigenen
offizieren erschossen worden
da ist ja kein abstand zwischen würde
das ist eine art henry schlagen oder
einen luftschlag je nachdem das halbe
korrekt also ich weiß nicht was sie da
schreiben
sie uns einmal ihren alltag sie sagten
sie gehen nachts auf patrouille was
erleben sie dort und wo sind sie jetzt
im moment welche möglichkeit haben sie
auch wenn der alarm wieder losgeht in
der hauptstadt sich in sicherheit zu
bringen
ich gehe nicht in sicherheit ich bin
entweder in der wohnung oder ich bin
draußen auf der straße ich war noch kein
millionen bunker meine frau ja die hat
dort versucht die die älteren bis hin zu
beruhigen und der angst hat obwohl sie
selber die hose vorlaute die hat sich
jetzt aber heute auf den weg gemacht die
ukraine zu belassen sie kann es örtlich
läuft es nicht mehr
letzte frage wir haben heute von paros
haben die bilder aus kiew gesehen wie
sich da ganz ganz viele die eben in der
hauptstadt geblieben sind eindecken
heute sozusagen vielleicht die letzte
chance noch einmal im supermarkt das zu
bekommen was man für die nächsten tage
wenigstens braucht haben sie sich
eingedeckt ist nun ja ich bin
vorbereitet also ich kann noch ein paar
wochen durchhalten wird und wer machen
sie sich jetzt von ihrer frau erst mal
getrennt welchen weg wählt er aus und
haben sie nicht auch mit dem gedanken
spielt zu begleiten
nein sie versuchten den zug nach nutzung
zu nehmen also entwickelt hatte nur ob
deshalb funktioniert ich weiß es nicht
ich drücke auf jeden fall die daumen und
das tun wir für sie herzlichen dank für
das gespräch dort nach gerne passen sie
auf sich auf